[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
um
i'll just slow down a little bit when
the drums
is
down the field my friends
[Music]
so
hello everyone
and welcome
so i am thrilled to announce
that the next dean of yale college is
pericles lewis the douglas tracy smith
professor
of comparative literature
and professor of english
thank you all for joining us for this
announcement
thanks to the yell
is that the precision marching band the
concert band random uh gotta thank you
tom duffy for assembling a band for us
today thank you so much
pericles is joined by his family his
wife sheila hair their cho their
daughter
uh maya and their son siddhartha
couldn't join us today
uh but he is watching on zoom i
understand
uh sheila is a graduate of
the yale law school and currently
teaches at the quinnipiac quinnipiac law
school
siddhartha graduated from yale college
two days ago with a bs in mathematics
we congratulate him and maya is a yale
college sophomore majoring in english
and biology
[Applause]
so many of you know professor lewis is
an internationally recognized expert on
the qualities and purposes of liberal
art of liberal education
he's been a talent he is a talented uh
been committed teacher and educator here
at yale since he joined the faculty in
1998
and has been deeply involved in
university life
ever since
in addition to teaching and writing and
editing
professor lewis has served now as the
vice president for global strategy and
as a vice provost
for academic initiatives
among his many contributions in those
roles
he worked with the yale school of public
health to launch an online
master's degree program
we worked with the jackson institute to
create a new master's degree program in
public policy
he's worked with the deans of medicine
nursing and public health
to establish the yell institute for
global health
and uh his role also included oversight
over the macmillan center the yale
center beijing
the young global scholars program and
many other departments
and centers
but his work
in
the education of students at yale goes
back
decades he was the director of
undergraduate studies in complete
back in 2000 from 2000 to 2006
and he helped integr integrate the two
majors that the department used to
sponsor he updated the curriculum
in 2005 he
uh
worked
on the undergraduate curriculum as a
member and later as chair
of the yale college committee on majors
and in his scholarly life
he works on
literary modernism he's the author of
three books on the social and
intellectual contexts of modern
literature and right now he is working
on a manuscript on the role of liberal
education
in developing character fostering
community preparing young people for
citizenship encouraging
the pursuit
of knowledge
now i think many of you know i'm
realizing you're all skewed to one side
i'm i'm getting you all only in one
hemisphere of my brain at the
at the moment but um
between 2012 and 2017
professor
lewis left yale to serve as the founding
president of yale nus
college he quickly established himself
as
an international authority on global
arts and sciences education
he oversaw the development of the yale
nus college curriculum which was a very
innovative
curriculum
he recruited diverse groups of students
and faculty and staff to work at yale
nus college
and as a result of this foundational
work yale nus college did what we hoped
it would do which was inspire
innovation in undergraduate education
uh
first at the national university of
singapore then throughout singapore then
through other institutions in asia and
ultimately
influence what we did here domestically
especially
in yale college
now some of you in this room have worked
with pericles over the past two years
especially on sustaining yells teaching
and
research missions during
covid that has not been easy and i wish
i could thank
individually so many of you in this room
who played important roles in getting us
through the last two years those roles
are not over yet i wish i could say they
were
but
pericles as you know uh uh was a very
important advisor on coven 19 because he
chaired the academic continuity
committee which was
which is essentially addressed how do we
keep going
how do we keep pursuing
research how do we keep pursuing
education and learning
uh
despite the challenges of covet he was
also a member of the operating policy
committee which translated
recommendations we were getting from
yale's unbelievable experts in the
health sciences particularly modeling
going on in the school of public health
how do you translate that into actions
we could take on campus so he worked in
partnership with faculty and staff and
students
and figured out
how and when we could welcome back
welcome students back to a safe campus
environment
and how we could educate them both
remotely and in person he oversaw the
poor center for teaching and learning
as you know they played a critical role
their staff played a critical role in
helping us convert to online and hybrid
education
during that time
he guided the university planning for
the opening of the schwartzman center we
are now
in commons of the schwarzman center this
beautiful room that has been preserved
historically
but uh in ways that are far more
functional than it used to
be down below i hope
virtually everyone in this room has seen
those beautiful spaces and of course
behind that wall all kinds of new uh
resources for uh students and the larger
yale community
he contributed to the planning of the
new yale jackson school for global
affairs
during this period of time as well
so
on july 1st
pericles will step down from all of
those other roles except for his
oversight of the schwarzman center
and assume the role of dean of yale
college
we will absorb
many of his previous functions
within the provost's office
and we're working that out now and
throughout the
summer
there is no doubt however that with his
international experience we will still
turn to pericles for advice
on all kinds of issues during these
geopolitically complicated
times he will though focus
on his partnerships with other
university leaders with the faculty with
the staff
uh guiding the curriculum the
intellectual life
of yale college student affairs in yale
college and of course with the heads of
the residential colleges and the deans
of residential college
the experience of life within the
residential communities
in doing so he will build on dean marvin
chun's immense accomplishments over the
last five years
for which we are
incredibly grateful i have more to say
about that in a moment
uh ensuring that an undergraduate
education at yale
is
unsurpassed
unsurpassed by any other
liberal arts college sitting in the
middle of a research
university it will be and continue to be
a model for the entire world
let me take a moment to thank the
search advisory committee members
chaired by professor
margaret clark who is also the head of
trumbull college uh and included
professor amy meredith cox dean
christina ferrando professor alan gerber
formidab former deputy dean joe gordon
professor tina liu
mayan chung from the class of 2023
professor david vassour and my chief of
staff susan gibbons who staffed the
committee they did enormous amounts of
outreach to the yale community
they provided thoughtful recommendations
and a very exciting
short list of potential
candidates
finally
finally
my heartfelt
gratitude
to my partner in crime here
dean marvin chun we are
dean chun and i have been colleagues in
the psychology department for
decades i was
involved in hiring him in the psychology
department twice
as well as his wife working on
and
one couldn't
have been blessed with a better
colleague
a more wonderful friend
and a dean
more committed
to the life
and education
of our undergraduates who have been an
outstanding leader
for yale college for the past five years
i know you share my excitement about
professor
pericles lewis's appointment
and before turning uh the podium over to
professor lewis i want to invite dean
chun to say a few words to us once again
thank you all for being here and thank
you for all that you do for yale
team 10
good afternoon
please excuse my mask i'm following
close contact protocols
i'm wondering where i got exposed
we just had commencement for 20 000
people
i'm delighted to welcome professor lewis
to the best job in academia
i've long admired his contributions to
yale
and his achievements as the founding
president of yalenus college
because i was involved in the planning
of yell nus
and served on their governing board i'm
in a pretty unique position to be in awe
of what he had accomplished there
professor lewis had
led yale nus college to become one of
the most innovative liberal arts
colleges around the globe
with a curriculum that is global and
inclusive
a residential life that successfully
incorporated the best features of yale's
residential colleges
while adapting to singapore context
if you want you can google yalenus
college sky garden
they have a faculty committed to
collaborative teaching a staff dedicated
to both a rigorous education and student
wellness and an internationally diverse
student body that like our students at
yale
are sought after by top institutions for
their love of learning and care for
others
i went into detail about them because
i'm excited for what professor lewis
will bring to your college
he begins his term
as etheneville college with more
administrative experience than i had
starting in this role
and more than i have now even after
completing a five-year term
so frankly i'm very flattered to see
such an academic superstar
leader as my successor
in turn i'm proud and happy to be
passing on a college that is flourishing
as best as one can after a challenging
two years for everyone
the yale college dean's office is more
collaborative
proactive
and resilient than before because that
is how the faculty staff and students
have all been
i'm grateful to president salovey for
entrusting me with this role
and i thank him for supporting yale
college and me
so strongly throughout my entire term
every significant request i made
such as the elimination of build student
effort and financial aid
and the camp yell orientation flip
he has granted with enthusiasm
i also thank provost scott strobel
he has provided all the guidance and
resources needed to manage through the
pandemic
culminating in the renaissance of
in-person campus life and two glorious
commencement weekends
provost strobel has positioned yale
college for greater success in the years
ahead
building on former provost ben pollock's
legacy
by approving significant enhancements to
financial aid
residential life student life and of
course
academic programs and facilities
it's kind of like starting with a blank
check
much of the college's work is powered by
our distinguished faculty colleagues led
by faculty of arts and sciences dean
tamar gendler
school of engineering and applied
science dean jeff brock and fas steering
group
yield college also works closely with
the graduate school led by lynn cooley
and we are grateful for our academic
partnerships with the professional
schools
where our undergraduate students are
fortunate to take classes and pursue
majors
i'd like to remind everyone here that
yield college depends on the entire
university and so i am grateful for
having worked regularly with the yale
alumni association yale athletics
chaplain's office facilities and grounds
general counsel yell health yell
hospitality
information technology services human
resources operations
police and public security
office of public affairs secretary's
office
and also other key offices that
professor lewis has supervised already
the registrar's office the purview
center conferences and events global
strategy and the schwartzman center
we have incredibly caring alumni parents
and friends who support our mission with
inspiring generosity and their gifts are
managed wisely by the three offices of
development investments and finance
i believe that yale has the most vibrant
residential college communities in the
world led by prominent heads deans and
staff members devoted to our students
i will always be proud and grateful to
have served as head of berkeley college
as much as i am to have served as dean
of yale college
each year
the yale college dean's office trains
over 200 student leaders first year
counselors peer liaisons peer mentors
communication and consent educators
committee members and student staff
members in our offices and cultural
centers
and working independently but in close
collaboration
yale college council is an essential
partner to help the dean understand and
support student needs
the yolk college dean's office itself
has over 230 outstanding staff members
across the offices of
academic affairs admissions and
financial aid administrative affairs
center for international and
professional experience strategic
initiatives and communication
the council of heads of college the
residential college dean's offices
development external affairs and special
projects
finance student affairs
student engagement and the cultural
centers and undergraduate education
led by fantastic senior associate deans
and directors i view each office to be
the best across all of higher education
my biggest joy in the deanship was
working with such brilliant and
dedicated colleagues who are now like a
second family to me
we've been through a lot
and my colleagues gave everything they
have day and night
without weekends or recess to the
students
to each other and me and to yale
uh friends i i really appreciate you and
i love you
dean lewis you will love them too the
entire yale college dean's office and i
are thrilled to support your deanship
thank you for accepting the role and
congratulations
[Applause]
thank you dean chun we so appreciate
your leadership
and now i'd like to introduce the next
dean of yale college pericles lewis
thank you so much president satellite
could i invite those who are at that end
of the room to come over into the middle
of the room if you're willing
it's good to get a little circulation
thank you
don't worry i won't keep you for too
long
thank you so much president salovey and
dean chun
president saliva thank you for your
leadership and for entrusting this
important role to me
um thanks also to the members of the
search advisory committee i i really
appreciate your confidence
and dean chun thank you for the
inspiring work that you have done in the
past five years under some of the
difficult circumstances that you
mentioned to lead this community
it's really a true honor
to be named your successor and i
appreciate your very kind words
next year will be the 25th
uh since i joined yale college as a
faculty member and started teaching
the college is a remarkable institution
dedicated to light and truth
and even though we may all pursue truth
by our own lights one of the great
things about the college is the way that
we work together we try and help light
each other's way
the fact that we're all pursuing truth
together is part of what makes this a
place of great learning
and communal joy
and what makes the four years that our
undergraduates spend with us
so transformative for them and also
truthfully transformative for us the
faculty and the staff
next academic year will be the fourth
year since the beginning of the pandemic
uh the class of 2023 has never known a
totally covet-free
year at yale and these last few years
have made the central act of yale
college which is learning together
somewhat more challenging considerably
more challenging i'd like to salute the
students
and the faculty
and especially the staff
who have persevered during challenging
times and have made it possible for us
to continue our educational mission and
also our great research
during this
challenging period
in particular i'm very grateful to the
heads
and the deans of the residential
colleges to the yale college
office dean's office staff to the staff
of the residential colleges and also of
course to our colleagues in hospitality
and facilities because they've
all of you together have kept this place
open and made it possible for students
to learn
even at a time when at times it has been
challenging and when guidelines on
public health have been changing and
sometimes it has been stressful i thank
you for that and i hope that this is a
an opportunity for some well-deserved
rest for people who've been working so
hard the last few years i also know that
many of you been through a difficult
period and i look forward to supporting
the staff and their essential roles
as we go forward
i believe that next year we'll have the
opportunity to recover from the worst of
kovid and to experience the
transformative communal life
of college together more intensely in
the arts and in athletics
in the residential colleges and the
cultural houses in study abroad and
volunteer work in the library and in the
laboratory
in the classroom and in extracurricular
activities and i look forward to
participating in that
next year will be the 323rd year of yale
college
the college began by educating young men
from connecticut and western
massachusetts in the liberal arts and
sciences
in the words of the charter to prepare
them for public employment both in
church and civil state
and only eight students graduated at the
first commencement in new haven more
than 300 years ago
since then
while the college's goal of educating
talented young people for future
leadership has not changed
yale has continually expanded not only
in terms of pedagogy not only in terms
of numbers but also in the range of
subjects we teach
the excellence of our curriculum and
pedagogy
and research and the diversity of our
student body
for almost a century the residential
colleges have created enduring
communities that are an essential part
of the broader yale ecosystem
i could not be prouder of the progress
that yale has made in the past 60 years
to become a college that better reflects
the great diversity of the united states
and that welcomes students regardless of
ability to pay
from around the world
there's of course much more work to do
and like our sister schools here and
abroad we've faced some tumultuous times
over the last few years but i believe in
a yale where everyone regardless of race
or socio-economic status
gender sexuality or gender identity or
expression
disability or veteran status
religious or political perspective or
national or ethnic origin can learn
together
and such an environment for learning
requires respect
and tolerance and a willingness to
listen to one another
most of all it requires an openness on
the part of each of us
an openness to learn and humility
excuse me
a humility about how little we actually
know
promise i won't do this every time i
make a speech
yale's world-leading research our
dedicated teachers our distinctive
residential system and what i think of
as the civil society of yale
the web of groups and traditions and
activities
that make up its unique
culture these are worth cherishing and
preserving
they've been underpinned over the years
by an ethos of service
while we of course want our students to
develop their talents
fully and their characters as
individuals
we also expect that yale alumni will
make broader contributions to the
communities that they choose to live in
and will use their capacities the
highest possible ends
so we hope that our students carry the
dedication to light and truth with them
beyond their four years in the college
thank you again for this honor i take it
on in a spirit of openness and humility
in closing i'd like to thank my family
some of whom are with me
and some of them are yale graduates and
as was mentioned one of whom is a very
recent yale graduate indeed
grateful to the teams in global strategy
and academic initiatives i'm happy to
see so many of you here
uh you've worked tirelessly over the
last five years to ensure that the
mission of this great university a
research university that as president
salovey has said
puts teaching at its core
remains central
to the team i'm joining in yale college
i look forward to getting to know you
better
to continue to provide the world's
greatest undergraduate education
to the faculty
thank you for your continued collegial
support and dedication to our mission
to the students
have a wonderful exciting restful summer
can't wait to see you all in the
academic in the new academic year and in
the words of the old yale football song
bulaboola i probably should have warned
the band about that so they could start
playing it but anyway thank you
let me just thank uh maya and sheila for
joining us today once again dean chun
for your incredible stewardship of yale
college
and professor lewis pericles-lewis thank
you for saying yes when i called you i
think you can all see this is a man who
uh whose emotional commitment to this
position is obvious and whose passion
for the uh position uh uh is uh so uh so
readily on display we're going to make
him wear a mask for all future speeches
however
uh thank you all for joining us today
for this announcement we have
refreshments courtesy of yale
hospitality we ask you to join us in
celebrating this moment uh by uh by
partaking thank you all for being here
and thank you all for what you do for
yale college
uh yes probably yes i think probably
you